tiens les effets des 35 heures sur les
vacances premier bilan des
professionnels du tourisme les départs
seraient de plus en plus fréquent mais
les séjours de plus en plus courts
en été la moyenne est de 16 jours
rappelons que l'an passé 65% des
français sont partis en vacances
90 % d'entre eux d'entre nous sont
restés en france
elisabeth est gelé nathalie jourdan
delphine de tri les étrangers fou de la
côte d'azur comme cette famille
polonaise ce n'est pas nouveau
ce qui a changé c'est qu'ils sont moins
gênés par les vacanciers français qui
eux raccourci de plus en plus leurs
congés d'été
on avait toujours une clientèle de
séjour est donc là on voit que c'est
vraiment une demande de trois jours 4
nuits vendredi samedi et dimanche
changement d'habitudes passage aux 35
heures qui permet de s'échapper tout au
long de l'année
la durée moyenne des vacances d'été de
deux semaines aujourd'hui contre 3 il y
a trente ans les voyagistes et s'adapte
grand succès des formules de 2 à 4 jours
le reste de l'année
cette offre connaît un succès
grandissant
nous avons augmenté la fréquentation des
courts séjours chez pierre & vacances de
21%
pendant les mois de mai et de juin dans
nos résidences française fini le mois de
vacances estival incontournable de plus
en plus citadin nous avons le bouge pas
ce qu'on appelle modèle français dans
les années 60 qui voyait des français
partir ceux qui partaient en vacances
jean 85 % entre juillet et août cette
proportion est descendue à 51% aux
derniers chiffres envie de bouger mais
aussi de se retrouver en famille ou
entre amis 40 % des français sont logés
gratuitement en vacances parce qu'ils
sont invités ou parce qu'ils occupent
leur résidence secondaire
un mode l'école